السياسه والكره متداخلتان كما ذكرنا تداخل
وصل الى الوان قمصان المنتخبات زيو
المانيا الابيض والاسود يرمز الى الوانه
فرساني التوتن الذين اسسوا اماره نظام
التوتن بعد غزوه روسيا في عام
1230 وسيطر على اراضي تقع اليوم ضمن حدود
دول استونيا لافيا ليتوانيا المانيا
بولندا روسيا والسويد اما اللون الاحمر
فيرمز الى عالم الامبراطوريه الالمانيه
التي تاسست في الثامن عشر من يناير عام
180 201
وانهارت بعد ثورته نوفمبر عام
1918 مع تنازلي اخر ملوكهام الثاني عن
العرش ولون الاخضر الكلاسيكي للالمان جاء
كنوع من الاعتراف بالجميل لمنتخب ايرلندا
الذي كان اول فريقا يدعو المنتخب
وطني لخوض مواجهه وديه بعد انتهاء الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وذلك في عام
1951 في ايطاليا عام
1946 وبعد تشكيل الجمهوريه قرر المنتخب
الايطالي الاستمرار بنفس اللون الازرق
لزياه الذي يرمز الى شعار العائله الملكيه
سابوي التي حكمت البلاد بين
1861 و
1946 ويعرف وعالميا باسمي ازرق الصبايا
كما ان من مملكه سردينيا احدى الممالك
التي اتحدتها التي تشكيلي ايطاليا في
الستينات القرن التاسع عشر كان علمها
يكتسيح اللون الازرق ايضا امازيه منتخب
هولندا البرتقالي الشهير
فجاءتكما للعائله الهولنديه اورانج التي
حكمت البلاد منذ الفن و
5044 وحتى اليوم